angelina jolie gracing the cover of
british vogue
a playful angie letting them inside her
home and her bag
chocolate for mom you know
the small pleasures in life i like
chocolate
angelina deserves a little chocolate
she's still in a custody battle with ex
brad and says quote
the past few years have been pretty hard
i've been focusing on healing our family
it's slowly coming back like the ice
melting and the blood returning to my
body
mom can you hold my phone mom can you
take this
something there i need this i usually
have snacks british vogue spent two days
at home with the oscar winner for their
march issue
she also explains why she recently moved
into the former hollywood estate
of cecil b demille quote i wanted to be
close to their dad who is only 5 minutes
away
are you like finding the silver lining
that all your kiddos
are back in one space together we've all
been used to being
tight together for a long time at 45
jolie says she's looking forward to her
50s but jokes we were on the trampoline
the other day and the children said
no mom don't do that you'll hurt
yourself there was a day i was an action
star and now
the kids are telling me to get off the
trampoline because i'll hurt myself